Why do we have this potential for
performance loss, with the microkernel based design?
Mainly because of the border crossings. That
is, going across hardware address spaces, can
be quite expensive. First there is this
explicit cost of switching the address space,
from one hardware address space to another
hardware address space. That is the explicit cost.
And in addition to the explicit cost
of going across address spaces, there are implicit
costs involved in this border crossing. And that
comes about because of change in locality. We're
going from one hardware address space to a
different address space, and that changes the locality
of execution of the processor. And that means
that me memory hierarchy, the caches in particular,
close to the processor, may not have the contents that are needed for
executing the code and accessing the data
structures of a particular server, different from
the application. A change in locality is
another important determinant of performance and it
can adversely effect the performance. And also,
when we are going across address spaces
to ensure the integrity of the system, either the micro kernel, or the server
that is living on top of the microkernel. There may be a need to copy from
user space to system space. And those
kind of copying of data from the application's
memory space into the microkernel and back out
to a server process. All of those can
result in affecting the performance of
the operating system. Whether they're in a
monolithic structure, since all the components
are contained within the same address space,
it is much easier for sharing data without copying. And that's one of
the biggest potential sources of performance loss
when we have this microkernel based structure.